NARRATOR: While it may seem
unthinkable that pyramids could
exist in Antarctica,
in recent years,
archaeologists have found
pyramids all over the world
that had been lost
for centuries,
mistaken as natural
formations or hidden
in the most unlikely places.
They have been discovered in the
plains of Northern Peru, buried
beneath dirt and
rubble in Indonesia,
and one may even exist in
Los Angeles, California.
All the way around
the world, we find
evidence of pyramid structures.
We should start looking
at the possibility
that there was
habitation on Antarctica.
Was it a lost civilization?
Could it be ancient astronauts?
And just maybe the
earliest monuments
of our own civilization came
originally from Antarctica.
If this gigantic
pyramid in Antarctica
is an artificial structure, it
would probably be the oldest
pyramid on our planet.
And in fact, it might
be the master pyramid
that all the other
pyramids on planet Earth
were designed to look like.
There has been extensive
research done on pyramids
throughout the world in
terms of their structure
and what it is that
they really are.
And one of the theories is that
pyramids are power generators.
And so if you have these
pyramids strategically placed
around the world
generating this charge,
it's possible to create
a general standing wave
around the world
that is basically
a wireless
transmission of energy.
It's been theorized
that ancient ships,
extraterrestrials and
those with high technology,
could use this interconnected
wireless energy system
to navigate around the planet.
And it makes sense that
if there was some kind
of worldwide pyramid power
grid like this, that Antarctica
would have pyramids as well.
The whole idea of these
pyramidal structures,
where did it come from?
It's not an arbitrary thing.
And these structures,
they exist worldwide.
So what was the impetus?
What's the origin?
And even more fascinating,
did they originate
on the Antarctic continent?
NARRATOR: Might the
pyramid Joseph White
claims to have discovered near
the Shackleton Mountain Range,
and other pyramid-shaped
formations recently
photographed in Antarctica,
provide evidence
of extraterrestrial
visitation to our planet
in the remote past?
And if they are actually
man-made structures,
how is such a thing
even possible in a place
that has been buried beneath the
ice for over 12 million years?
According to ancient
astronaut theorists,
Antarctica may not have been
a frozen continent for as long
as mainstream
scientists suggest.
And they say proof can
be found by examining
a 500-year-old map depicting
the continent without any ice.